we have this tweet from Rand Paul it's a
meme made by being libertarian and
ladies and gentlemen is one of the best
memes I've ever seen it says Netflix
presents Hillary and it's a picture of
Nikki Haley and it is masterfully done
Rand Paul of course released an
anti-s with never nii.net where uh he's
basically given his message so far
there's no heavy endorsement but he's
just saying at least not Nikki Haley I
think this meme purpose
I mean I'm sorry um perfectly
encapsulates wokeness Netflix Netflix
the Democrats and why Nikki Haley is
Nikki Hillary they nailed it amazing job
question though do you think that Rand
Paul's negative endorsement is going to
make more or less people vote for Nikki
Haley because they say even bad press is
good press I I think the most powerful
tool we have in the culture war and even
in politics mockery yeah and so if you
come out I'll tell you this you go to
the average person and you say Nikki
Haley lied about what Russia's
intentions are in in in Eastern Europe
to ex expand foreign war and get us to
spend money and I'm telling you if she's
elected we're going to see war in the
Middle East they're going to go if you
go up to the average person and go yo
look at this Nikki Nikki Halley Hillary
they're gonna start laughing their asses
off that mockery reaches the average
person because it's the lowest common
denominator it reaches some of them
because some other people be like oh
what do you show me that crap for like
and just be like turned off by and be
like don't make fun of Don't Be Cruel
don't bring sure some people but the
point is making a coherent political
argument about Nikki Haley's awful
foreign policy and who she's aligned
with and where she gets her donations
from is so over the toop esoteric the
average person says look I I don't know
what you're talking about dude but if
you show a meme that makes fun of
Netflix wokeness and how they do this
they do these diversity castings it
makes people laugh and and the idea why
is she why is she white though shouldn't
she be black if this is a real uh but
that's the point she she is she's the
minority minity Clinton but if it was a
real Netflix special Nikki and Hillary
wouldn't even be on there right they
it'd be some black woman cuz I was told
that you the only way you get a Netflix
special is if you're you know a black
black that's the point n Haley is a
minority maybe maybe I'm just black pill
I feel like I shouldn't have to explain
to the American people why they
shouldn't support Niki Haley at this
point like if you if you've been alive
for the past 20 years and you've seen
what the the neocons have done and the
Neo progressives or the neoliberals or
whatever you want to classify the
clintons as or Obama for that matter and
I and you still haven't figured out that
like everything they've told you has
been a lie and it has just destroyed the
world destroyed your financial
well-being I I still have to explain to
you that Nikki Haley is not a good
option for president I can't even
believe this chick's running it's
unbelievable bro of course you have to
explain it the average person doesn't
know anything about foreign policy or
politics and Nikki Haley goes on stage
and the average person I'm not talking
about people who are into politics you
could be left or right the average
person who decides for some reason to
watch is going to see Nikki Haley go
Vladimir Putin is going to go after
Poland and our allies you know she does
that thing where she doesn't open her
mouth when she talks it's really weird
but she's going to be like he's going to
invade he's like Hitler and they go you
know I don't know who this lady is or
anything about Russia but that sounds
scary then Donald Trump will say
something in his show he'll be like it's
not correct you know Vladimir Putin is
he's he wants Crimea and they're going
to say huh who do I believe the way the
reason why memes are so effective is
that that regular person sees Donald
Trump memes where he's riding a t or
Velociraptor with a machine gun and they
laugh that mockery of trump and it is
but it's positive it's like look how
strong and tough he is Nikki Haley is in
is insulted as a bad Hillary Clinton who
everyone hates then when someone when
you're when you're sitting with your
friends and you turn on the debate or
whatever it is you're watching and she
says those lies about Vladimir Putin
that person goes she's she's Hillary
Clinton dude Hillary Clinton's stupid
yeah I think that memes are ammunition
in the Arsenal of persuasion and they're
not to be used on every Target Target
like just the illiterate just yeah they
work against certain people that they'll
be like haa yeah but other times you've
got to explain her her role on the board
of Boeing and that she's part of War
Machine and you're correct but everybody
hates Hillary Clinton she was one of the
most despised candidates we've ever seen
and that's one of the reasons she lost
in 2016 so when you show a picture of
Nikki Haley and call her Hillary the
people who don't know anything about it
instantly understand what that means I
would say though that we're living in
different times I I do think that
mematic Warfare is certainly uh you know
influential uh but but the reality is is
that this isn't about oh well I like
Nikki Haley I'm going to vote for Nikki
Haley this is about one thing and one
thing only okay and that is getting
Donald Trump and that's why you have
David plof who is uh Barack Hussein
Obama's former campaign manager urging
Democrats to show up on caucus day in
Iowa to change their registration to
Republican to vote for Nikki Haley it's
not that people actually like Nikki
Haley I'm sure that Democrats and
Republicans both recognize the fact that
she's a warmonger and a neocon who you
know has a has a board position with
Boeing and has really shady ties to
defense contractors that made her a
multi-millionaire but this is this is
about getting Donald Trump and so they
are still going to vote I I think that
Donald Trump's going to overwhelmingly
win the Iowa caucus but that's why
you're seeing all of Hillary Clinton's
donors people like Reed Hoffman okay
who's the second largest Democrat Party
Mega donor after George Soros line up to
support Nikki Haley they don't actually
care about Nikki Haley it's not like
they really care about her policies they
just want to get Trump whoever that is
they don't care they're I think they're
even pushing for a contingent election
that's why RFK pack just invested $15
million in uh key key swing States
because they're by their own admission
they said that their goal is to get 15
electoral votes so that neither Joe
Biden nor Donald Trump get 270 and then
what happens uh per the Constitution
with a contingent election is Congress
Cong then gets to decide who our
president is house delegations yes so
but Republicans out outnumber that but
with we currently have a one-seat
majority because with all these
Republicans retiring we could have
speaker hakee Jeff by March if one of
these geriatrics in Congress has a
stroke gets cancer has a heart attack
dies gets in a car accident or resigns
because they have whatever some kind of
family emergency we already know that
there's a ton of rhinos in Congress who
hate Trump and they would love to screw
Donald Trump in in an election year by
saying you know what we're just going to
retire early and uh there you go speaker
Jeff that's why Kevin McCarthy retired
early and that's why they ousted George
Santos this is a this is a good point
though because one play to consider
though I don't know how likely it would
be is if a few of the Rhinos in Congress
resign giving Democrats the slim
majority by having maybe a seat gives
them the delegations and not even the
delegations but once they have Congress
they immediately vote to uh to charge
Trump with Insurrection or they simply
just pass a resolution saying Trump is
an insurrectionist I truly believe
that's their strategy I think that the
rhinos are are doing that and I wouldn't
be surprised if by March and people can
record this and there's going to be a
recording we'll see if I'm right I think
by the end of March we're going to see
another Republican resign and the
Democrats are going to take back control
of the house well if that happens I mean
I'm just curious you're you're one of
Trump's biggest supporters I'm his
biggest supporter okay his biggest
supporter I
apologize number one fan if if he is uh
you know whed if he's robbed if he's
thrown off of enough uh State ballots
that he's whatever reason it's
illegitimate and he's kept out of office
how how is the Maga base going to react
to that well there's going to be a
revolution in this country we are voting
for president Trump regardless of
whether or not his name's on the ballot
they're not going to steal our elections
from us and this is why everybody should
be appalled by these Soros funded
secretaries of States uh like Jenna
Griswald in Colorado or Shaina Bellow in
Maine who are you know removing
president Trump's name
unconstitutionally from the ballot and
that's my point about the contingent
election right if they are successful
like let's say the Supreme Court rules
against President Trump right he won't
get the electoral votes in those States
and it will set a precedent and allow
for other blue States or states with
Rhino or democrat secretaries of state
to remove him from the ballot under uh
section three of the 14th Amendment and
so you see the possibility become more
of of reality right of of of neither
candidate getting 270 especially with
the way that RFK junior is being so
heavily funded as an independent I think
V was saying one of the plays is it's
not about the Democratic party you know
we we've talked about oh you know the JP
Morgan guys say Joe Biden's gonna have a
medical issue in March he's goingon to
drop out and then we speculate it was it
going to be Newsome is it going to be
Michelle Obama when it's been Nikki
Haley the whole time they they the B say
they're not going that route they're
going from within the party they're
propping up H Nikki Haley who is very
obviously like you you put her next to
Hillary Clinton and take the same
talking points same thing Russia Russia
Russia all this foreign foreign policy
garbage keeps hot sauce in her purse
right see there you go and uh but the
point is when they're taking Trump off
the ballot people say who cares if
Trump's off the ballot in Colorado
Colorado's a blue State yes but it's the
primary ballot now he's back on of
course but if California does it Trump
needs to win the California GOP Primary
it's not about the general election they
want to create a situation in which
Nikki Haley somehow wins the nomination
to give them some kind of legitimacy
against Trump yeah I think Trump will
run as independent regardless but then
they split the vote and it's like you
said contingent election interesting I
I'm very nervous because even if Say Say
by some miracle Trump beats all the all
the charges and he's actually on the
ballots and he wins the election and he
gets into power and the and the Deep
State doesn't take him out that's a lot
of ifs all right but he gets through all
those ifs and he and he and he finally
gets in there I still think we're
looking at the potential for a
revolution in this country just because
I think that the the media and the Deep
state will activate the left in this
country in a way that's extraordinarily
dangerous maybe we need one honestly I
mean maybe we need one no I don't want
to live through that no the country is a
reol I mean I'm just saying that our
country okay our country was born in a
revolution and so maybe in order to take
our country back we're going to need a
revolution I'm not calling for a civil
war I'm not inciting violence but I am
saying that you know people get so
scared with the words oh Revolution and
you know they they like to say that uh
Trump supporters are insurrectionist
weren't our founding fathers technically
speaking insurrectionists weren they
what if they lost yeah they were for
sure terrorists they were considered but
but hold on re Revolution doesn't always
mean violence exactly that's my point I
think but historically it typically is
related to it because the people in
power won't I think of it a lot as a
revolution of the mind I've been
thinking of it since but that's what Mao
called the the cultural revolution in
China too they were like it's a
revolution of the mind and like so if
we're going to do that which we kind of
are with shows like this we've got to be
really intricate about how we do it
revolution of Truth a revolution of
truth but but let's let's clarify
because
I like the founding father's vision for
this country I like the Constitution I
think it's brilliant I really do think
people should study the found like read
the Constitution read the how the
branches of government are meant to
operate read the founding father's
quotes and how they were coming up with
this system you've got they were like
should we have a monarchy no that's
crazy because of this problem should we
have a direct democracy no because of
this problem what about a Council of
Elders no this hey what about all three
of them and they all kind of argue with
each other at once it's like maybe
that's the best way to do it I don't
think it's a re ution we want I think
it's a reignition I think it's a um a
reaffirmation or more importantly a
cleansing or accountability for too long
people in this country have grown
complacent sitting by and letting
corrupt people exploit the system
Congress is plagued with corruption we
can see it in their stock trading deals
all we need to do is we don't we don't
want to Revolution in the sense of the
classical sense of changing this country
no we want to restore it which means a
restoration restoration is a good way to
put it yeah thanks for watching this
clip from the Tim C IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net